first let's start talking uh working
with mayam were you a fan before doing
this
i was and then obviously ever the more
so now
and uh had you started like when you
find out you're working with mayam are
you suddenly like a massive jeopardy fan
now too
you know that was just her she was kind
of just beginning that journey as we
were working together and so we had all
watched her and been such a fan of what
she was initially
doing and uh so it's very unsurprising
that now she is full in the swing of a
head and it's such a fantastic i mean
she can do everything i don't know how
much you know but she has a podcast
that's amazing her in front of the
camera behind the camera jeopardy just
mom
super mom so um yeah i it's she can do
it all
when it comes to be working with a
first-time director but somebody who has
also
grown up in show business and grown up
on sets i'm wondering what you picked up
on as far as her years of experience
when it came to the vibe that she
created yeah just so natural as you can
imagine um
she really belongs on set in every
capacity and that was just the overall
feeling we were a small but mighty crew
and it was just such a pleasure to be
involved in that storytelling it was
really personal for me it was obviously
personal for mayam and for every one of
uh us as actors everybody brought a lot
of personal truth to that film
i i have to wonder as an actor you may
think that you know one day down the
line you're going to play you know
out of family drama or a family comedy
and then you sort of envision who may be
your parents who would you get who would
you get paired up with yeah dustin and
candace where do they sort of rank on
your fantasy list of movie parents super
super high obviously um candace had
played my mom in another film 10 years
prior so really
yeah yeah it's this film called the
romantics and so that was super special
to re-engage with her in a
in a adult way you know i was a baby
then i was 22. um so it's more than 10
years but um yeah i just with the two of
them
first of all they've known each other
for
most of their lives from being you know
small people and living growing up in la
and
just the storytelling that you're able
to access
with them is phenomenal they're so
generous with um
with uh kind of career stories and and
uh what you know their own personal
experiences have been project to project
so every day i felt
more confident to ask more questions and
just really go through the rolodex of
their work uh and when you work with
dustin hoffman who can really do
everything and dustin hoffman's playing
your father yeah this ain't meet the
[ __ ] dustin hoffman this is a very
different um dustin hoffman what was it
like to
just know somebody so well from their
work and that's the that's the one you
get on set that's the character that's
the character you get what was that like
for you
well
you know i've uh
i guess
where
life and art really intersect in this
moment is you know i've had a sick
father and my father's been sick for
more years of my life than he's been
well unfortunately
and
just seeing how you know obviously our
stories are nowhere near carbon copy um
but just seeing how
dustin incorporated that um
the degradation of his health into that
character and how vulnerable he could be
and how tender that could feel and you
know it was just really uh moving
and kind of a wild feeling and then of
course we have flashbacks that show him
at a healthier and you know uh
very
altered uh kind of mental state and what
that was like also i mean i was playing
15 and 16 again which is such a wild
feeling for me just the duality of those
two versions of him was really
interesting and i really enjoyed uh
kind of those
opposite experiences
do you was there ever any hesitation to
do this because of your your own father
and your situation where maybe the days
might be a little bit too hard
i think that in years prior
yes and i remember
in one of these funny moments where
i
had recognized
a year prior that i was finally ready to
dip my toe in whatever kind of
you know father-daughter complicated
health relationship um
storytelling whatever that might bring
and then it came twofold both with this
movie with mayam and this other film
that'll be coming out this year um and
it's wild and weird when you get what
you ultimately kind of are asking for
but i do think that
it felt
you know i've done so much processing
around that and i think that
there's a there's there's beauty to it
as well you really i think
can
put stock in what you have had with
somebody and
even if it's not as many years or
moments as you would have wished for i
think you can still relive those
experiences in your mind and uh and be
thankful that you have those you know
when you finish a project is there
always sort of a group chat that exists
from that project and what is the group
what is that what is the group chat is
there a group chat for this one and
who's it there's a group there's a group
email for this one
um i wouldn't say that it's
enormously active um but i think also
too that is not reflective of any lack
of love or or desire to be sharing
meanwhile the i have you know a couple
others where it is so active i have a
group chat um from a film that i uh both
acted and produced last year and it's 20
of us always firing off you know photos
from set and storytelling and happy
birthday to all and you know so that's
very active and maybe makes up for the
ones that aren't i'm gonna say i i can't
picture dustin hoffman as a meme sender
i no
no
i can't say that i often saw him with a
phone on his person so yeah fair enough
the movie was great you were great in it
congratulations on everything i really
appreciate your time thank you
you